Every year of every day, thousands of people fall victim to FWP...
...also known as First World Problems.
I'm so cold, somebody set the AC to 72; I need it at 73.
Starving, all we have is leftovers.
Nobody cares about me.
Nobody commented or liked my status.
Hi, I'm Ryan Higa, and for just five hours of attention a day,...
...you could help somebody with FWP.
Everyone keeps putting so much pressure on me.
I don't know what I want for my birthday.
I have too much chips for my dip,...
...but if I open a new dip, I'll have too much dip for my chips.
Why does Apple keep making new iPhones?
Now I have to get another one.
They've been through so much struggle,...
...so much hardship,...
...so much attention.
Show your support and send them this video...
...and show them how much we care about their FWPs.
All you have to do is call the URL, 1-800-DOT-ORG.